so ELO wants to call in and share some
kind of news with us something about the
pregnancy I understand okay so you got
the results from the doctor this is the
result of them taking out the eggs we
did the eggs retrieval so we got seven
which is a lot that's awesome that's
like a lot yeah yeah and then I was like
okay and I've been waiting to hear the
gender so out of the seven you have six
boys and one girl oh boy God what is
it
I said we will they're all gonna be boys
I can't believe it did she tell you the
rating on the eggs she said they're all
beautiful they're all beautiful eggs
gorgeous eggs I believe that
dude that girl is seriously a miracle